bom dia pessoal eu sou mariana
vasconcelos
eu sou do sul de minas estou filha de
agricultores
eu cresci na fazenda e acompanhei o dia
a dia ea dificuldade de área do produtor
rural
eu acompanhei a escassez de mão de obra
a necessidade de estar nos campos todos
os dias pra observar e tentar entender o
que tinha que ser feito com a plantação
a preocupação do meu pai e não saber se
o que ele estava fazendo estava correto
baseando suas decisões na intuição no
conhecimento passado por gerações e até
do que o vizinho estava fazendo pra
decidiu que ele tinha que fazer com o
passar dos anos eu comecei a notar como
que as mudanças climáticas estava
impactando naquilo que a gente conhecia
sobre a nossa produção e como aquilo
estava afetando a produção de renda da
nossa região
foi a partir daí que eu quis criar algo
que tornasse nosso cultivo mais
inteligente e eu vim aqui hoje para
compartilhar com vocês é a minha paixão
ea minha visão sobre os desafios ea
visão de futuro da agricultura e por que
falar de agricultura é um tema que
apesar de estar no nosso dia a dia a
gente raramente pára pra pensar e
discutir sobre isso
a agricultura é uma das bases econômicas
do nosso país e corresponde a 23% do
nosso piri até a década de 60 e 70 o
brasil era o país do café e da cana de
açúcar porque a gente não tinha nem
conhecimento e nem tecnologia para
produzir outras coisas e expandir as
nossas fronteiras enquanto outras
indústrias como o petróleo energia e
construção usavam e adotavam tecnologias
estrangeiras
o mesmo não aconteceu com a agricultura
apesar da revolução verde
nós éramos na época a única potência
agrícola que possui o clima tropical
então não bastava simplesmente importar
tecnologia porque elas não funcionavam
para a nossa realidade para nossa
realidade
isso impulsionou com que a gente fosse
obrigado a aprender e desenvolver a
nossa própria tecnologia
hoje o brasil é o principal produtor e
exportador de café cana de açúcar e suco
de laranja além de seu líder de vendas
e no complexo de soja em 2030 é esperado
que um terço de toda a comercialização
agrícola no mundo venha do brasil e
apesar de a gente ter é essa tecnologia
no nosso histórico
a agricultura tem vivenciado muitos
desafios o primeiro deles é que a gente
tem que alimentar 9 bilhões de pessoas
em 2050
isso implica que a nossa produção tem
que ser aumentada em 70% a quase
totalidade desse aumento de produção
deve vir do aumento de produtividade
apenas 10% disso corresponde a uma maior
área plantada e mesmo que a gente
consiga superar esse desafio e produzir
70% mais a gente precisa investir em
acesso aos alimentos
senão a gente vai ter 370 milhões de
pessoas passando fome o que representa
cinco por cento da população dos países
em em desenvolvimento
um segundo problema é que a irrigação é
vista hoje como nos principais meios de
aumentar a produtividade porque ela
permite o plantio fora de época então
você pode ter mais de uma safra no ano
ela permite plantio em regiões que antes
não eram cultiváveis como por exemplo o
nosso cerrado para algumas culturas e
quando você faz um manejo correto da
irrigação entrega para a planta aquilo
que ela precisa no momento correto você
automaticamente aumenta sua performance
de desenvolvimento e aumentar a
produtividade
hoje apenas 20 por cento da área
cultivada no mundo é irrigada
mas ela corresponde a 44% dos nossos
alimentos
a conclusão é a gente precisa jogar mais
pra gente produzir produzir mais e
conseguir alimentar aquelas pessoas mas
ao mesmo tempo a gente está sofrendo é
com falta d'água
a califórnia israel brasil estão
sofrendo com secas que têm limitado a
irrigação hoje a gente consome 72 por
cento da nossa água doce na irrigação ea
gente desperdiça quase metade disso
por falta de conhecimento dos
agricultores em como agir em quando e
ligar
enquanto de água utilizar e mesmo que
parte dessa água seja devolvida para o
meio ambiente a gente tem um
desequilíbrio mas que essa água volte
pro solo raramente chove no mesmo lugar
e essa água volta pela mesma bacia
o terceiro problema são as mudanças
climáticas que vêm aí pra complicar um
pouco mais a cada um grau que a gente
tem de aumento de temperatura
a gente perde 2 por cento em
produtividade então a gente está
irrigando produzir mais mas o clima está
mudando e está reduzindo a nossa
produtividade ao mesmo tempo
isso requer e sementes adaptadas e mais
resistentes a esse tipo de mudança
uma outra implicação das mudanças
climáticas são que elas vão redistribuir
geograficamente agricultura então
lugares que antes eram muito frio e que
não podia ser plantado agora vão passar
a ser outras potências agrícolas que são
conhecidas pela sua produtividade podem
usar não ser mais elegíveis é para
alguns
alguns tipos de cultura hoje se um
agricultor que é iniciar o seu cultivo
ele pode procurar por exemplo embrapa
emater e perguntar pra minha região que
eu tenho que fazer
qual é a melhor cultura qualquer melhor
tipo de semente com a quantidade de água
e ao qual é o clima ideal e seguir essa
receita para começar a produzir
mas nessas condições mudam a gente não
tem mais a referência do que é certo eo
que é errado
a gente não sabe o que fazer a gente tem
que começar a aprender tudo de novo como
é que eu planto isso aqui aquilo lá eu
imagino que vocês devem estar um pouco
confusos agora com esse tanto de
informação e um pouco com medo do que
vem pela frente
e é exatamente assim que o agricultor se
sente
ele está sendo pressionado pela nossa
sociedade por uma agricultura mais
sustentável maior produção
mas ele tem que usar menos recursos a
cada vez mais difícil ele reage às
mudanças e saber como tomar decisões
bom é é fácil a gente esquecer o quanto
a tecnologia que a empregada até que o
alimento chegue à nossa mesa
a gente tem milhares de cientistas e
empreendedores criando tecnologia está a
alimentar milhões de pessoas ea vantagem
de se ter todos esses desafios é que
todo o desafio uma oportunidade
a agricultura é agora o mercado quente
que está pedindo por inovações e novas
tecnologias desde mudanças de
comportamento do consumidor é edição
genética de alimentos plantações em
cidades em um espaço é impressão 3d de
alimentos fazem os inteligentes e
inovação e modelos de negócios que
conectam diretamente produtores
consumidores finais por exemplo eu
escolhi alguns tópicos para a gente
poder conversar
o primeiro deles é a descentralização da
agricultura
um terço dos nossos alimentos que são
perdidos ou desperdiçados em países em
desenvolvimento essa pec é
principalmente antes da colheita nos
processos em países desenvolvidos essa
perca é após a colheita na distribuição
armazenamento e consumo
acredita se que a audi centralizar a
agricultura e trazer o cultivo para
centros urbanos para dentro de casa é
possível reduzir essa perca istribuição
e armazenamento e um dos modos de fazer
isso acontecer
é através de cultivos verticais então
você pode passar a cultivar frutas é
vegetais na sua própria casa todo mundo
pode passar a ser um agricultor podem
ser criadas redes entre vizinhos que
podem compartilhar a comida entre si as
cidades podem usar parques é trilhado de
prédios e espaços urbanos para plantar
comida ao invés de plantar grama e
distribui esses alimentos
o conceito de fazendas verticais acabou
testando e métodos de agricultura como
por exemplo o cultivo sem solo e isso
permitiu o cultivo em estações espaciais
então quando a gente pensa em transição
da agricultura
a gente não fala só como que eu não
confio apenas em grandes sistemas de
produção em zonas rurais e de água para
as cidades e consigo dinamizar
facilitando o acesso reduzindo custo é é
tendo maior produção porque você
consegue produzir o ano inteiro em
ambiente controlado com maior
produtividade mas também expandir essas
fronteiras agrícolas do acaso quem sabe
no futuro planeta terra não seja
suficiente pra gente
posso plantar o segundo ponto que eu
gosto de destacar bastante é a parte de
biotecnologia e genética de um lado a
gente tem inovações genéticas melhorando
sementes para que elas sejam mais
resistentes aquelas mudanças climáticas
que a gente falou e criando mais
variedades de sementes
hoje a gente tem um banco mundial de
sementes que possuem sementes do mundo
inteiro e diversos tipos que ficam numa
localidade protegida para no caso de um
grande desastre é uma guerra um um golpe
nuclear a gente tem acesso novamente a
semente possamos replicar esses cultivos
ea gente pode dar um passo além e não só
modificar a planta em si mas também
diretamente à nossa com a nossa a nossa
comida baseado pela tendência de que 18
por cento dos gases do efeito estufa são
produzidos pelo gado e 70% das nossas
áreas aráveis é são destinados à
alimentação de gado é empreendedores
americanos pensaram porque não utilizar
toda essa área e redirecionar esse
alimento é pra para os humanos e
utilizar carne in vitro
então eles utilizaram células tronco de
gados para replicar essa textura e criar
uma uma carne totalmente feita em
laboratório
alguém aqui comeria uma carne 100% feito
em laboratório
pode ser que a gente não tem escolha uma
outra inovação na frança utiliza é o
eles aqui a nossa comida editando como
se fosse um programa de computador a
genética da nossa comida colocando
bactérias para que no processo de
fermentação elas gerem mais vitaminas
ferro e zinco
este caso aconteceu na índia pela
própria empresa francesa onde eles
utilizaram é bolinho de arroz que são
base da dieta alimentar para colocar
essas bactérias para ter uma comida mais
nutritiva ajudando na segurança
alimentar e por fim nós temos o conceito
de agricultura digital de smartphone que
eu acredito que seja um conceito que
está mais fácil e mais abertamente
disponível para que a gente começa a
impactar agora então pra que a gente
consiga aumentar nossa produtividade
nesse ritmo é extremamente necessário
que a gente
mas sem entender o mais rápido possível
o nosso ambiente à nossa cultura dos
nossos processos e que a gente possui
informações para tomar melhores decisões
e pra que a gente tem essas informações
a gente precisa de sensores coletando
esses dados com o avanço da tecnologia a
redução exponencial dos custos de
sensores eletrônicos processamento
computacional com computação em nuvem ea
expansão da internet foi possível trazer
o conceito de internet das coisas do
campo em soluções por exemplo como
tratores inteligentes que possuem piloto
automático e possuem uma rota por gps
que economiza combustível e reduz a
compactação e erosão do solo máquinas
agrícolas com precisão para acolher para
plantar para fazer aplicações drone
imagens de satélite que permitem mapear
as terras fazer uma expectativa de
produtividade e identificar falhas na
plantação sensores que permitem
acompanhar a saúde das vacas e rastrear
toda a nossa cadeia de alimentos desde o
produtor até o usuário final e foi nessa
parte da cadeia que eu escolhi trabalhar
criando a agre smart e para explicar um
pouquinho como que o smart usa o
conceito de smartphone
eu queria contar pra vocês a história do
seu josé o seu josé é um agricultor
também no sul de minas gerais que é
tradicional que sempre confiou na sua
intuição para tomar suas decisões
o seu josé tinha pouco controle sobre
essa plantação ele não sabe exatamente
quanto de água e energia que ele
utilizava o que era um problema devido
aos altos custos da irrigação e as
regulamentações governamentais
além disso os funcionários josé tinham
que ir ao campo todos os dias para
tentar entender o que estava acontecendo
como estava sendo desenvolvida a
plantação se tinham doença se tinham
pragas e vai terminar a ligação o mais
utilizado era bater no solo com o bico
da bota e sentir qualquer resposta se
soltava circulam agora com a gripe marte
o seu josé conectado a sua plantação
então nós possuímos sensores espalhados
que monitoram mais de dez variáveis
ambientais
nós lemos esses sensores indianos pela
internet e analisamos em tempo real para
que a gente possa gerar recomendações
seu josé aquele tomem decisões melhores
em relação à irrigação doenças e pragas
o objetivo é que à medida que a gente
cresça a gente consiga entender mais
sobre nosso ambiente e criar melhores
práticas para os nossos agricultores
para que a gente consiga subir para um
novo é nível de produção
ao utilizar o smart na última safra o
seu josé e nossos outros agricultores
conseguiram economizar até 60% da água
utilizada 30% de energia e aumentar a
produtividade em 15%
além disso a qualidade de vida deles
mudou é muito mais simples acompanhar a
sua fazenda seu cultivo de onde você
tiver e saber que você está tomando a
decisão certa e conseguir compartilhar
isso com seus colegas do que está
simplesmente todos os dias lá sem poder
dormir acordar às 5 horas da manhã
podendo viajar no final de semana porque
não sabe se vai ter uma geada
a gente acredita que é importante a
gente não só vim agora combater a crise
alimentícia que a gente tem a crise
climática que a gente tem é importante a
gente entender o nosso ambiente e como
ele está mudando pra que a gente possa
prevenir futuras crises
o meu objetivo é que hoje foi deixar
vocês pensando um pouquinho sobre
agricultura porque a gente fala na
comida a gente fala em tudo na educação
a gente não consegue ter gente sentada
na sala de aula eles não estão bem
alimentados a gente não consegue
trabalhar se a gente não tá bem
alimentado e eu espero que vocês se
engajem mais com esse assunto e quem
sabe na ação aí outros empreendedores em
tecnologias na agricultura para que a
gente possa junto criar um mundo mais
sustentável
obrigada